You're
Testing. Testing. One, two, three.
Hello.
How is everyone this evening?
>> Yay. I'm happy to hear that. Welcome to
the table. We are so glad you are here.
Hello to our online friends. Nice to see
you as well. So glad you are here. Um
so couple of announcements as we get
started. First announcement, next week
will be our um open table. I got to
remember what to call it. Un Sunday
Unbound. That's what it is. Um we will
be doing it a little different than
we've done in the past months. So we'll
meet here. We'll do a worship service
and then we're going to go to Hat Creek
and have dinner together as a nice big
group and get some small chats. So, and
children will have a playground to play
at and it'll be a great time. I will be
there. So, I look forward to seeing all
of you if you can make it. Um, second,
North Texas Pride is coming up on
October 11th. We will be doing a booth.
Um, if you would like to volunteer um or
get more information about that, you can
scan the QR code that will pop up and um
you can get that there. You can sign up
there um or get more information. And
then thirdly, um Fall Fest. So, kids, we
will be hosting a Fall Fest for families
on October 17th. That is a Friday night.
So, that's kids up through 6th grade.
Um,
save the date for the fun night of
pumpkin carving, painting at the Runford
home in Saxi. There will be games and
snacks as well as a pumpkin carving
contest or pumpkin painting for the
littles. Um, scan the QR code to RSVP.
Um, so that's the download on what's
going on the next couple weeks here. Um,
slot us into your calendar if you can.
We're excited to have you. Um, so as we
finish that up, um, transition into
worship time. Um,
if you have accessibility needs, there's
a bucket over to the left. If it gets
too loud for you or you need something
to do with your hands, those tools are
available for you. We just ask that you
return them at the end of service. Um,
we've lit the candles to my left and
right. Um,
as a sign of the presence of Christ
among us, both fully divine and fully
human. Um
so join with me as we exit the kingdom
of noise, hurry and productivity. We
enter a kingdom of silence, stillness,
and simplicity. A sacred space, a place
for prayer, worship, and adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thank you. If you guys want to stand
with us, we're going to start with some
worship
and Gary's going to start us out on this
first song called Father's House. So,
you guys sing along if you are able. Um
or if not, just sit back and enjoy.
[Music]
Sometimes on this journey get lost. loss
of my mistakes.
Looks to me like weakness is akin to
slow you straight. My story isn't over.
My story's just begun.
Fear you won't define me. That's what my
father does.
father does. Ooh.
Lay your burdens down. Ooh.
Here in the father's house. Check your
shame at the door. Sitting ain't welcome
anymore.
Ooh,
you're in the father's house.
[Music]
I was not the end game. The journey's
where you are.
Never wanted perfect. You just wanted my
heart and the story isn't over, but the
story isn't good. None. Failure is never
final. When the father's in the room, I
said failures never final. When the
father's in the room, oh wo,
lay your burdens down. Wo wo
here in the father's house. Check your
shame at the door. Say welcome anymore.
Oh,
you're in the father's house.
[Music]
>> Father's house.
Prodigals come home.
Help us find hope.
Love is on the move. When the father's
in the room,
prison doors sling by.
Dead come to life.
Love is on the move. When the father's
in the room,
>> miracles take place. The cinn
is breaking through and the father's in
the room.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Jacles walls are breaking, strongholds
now shaking. Love is breaking through
and the father's in the room.
Love is breaking through when the
father's in the room. Wo!
Lay your burdens down. Wo wo
here in the father's house. Check your
shame at the door. any welcome anymore.
You're in the father's house.
>> No shame here. No shame here.
[Music]
All right. Thanks, Gary. Kids, you guys
are dismissed to your classes. Your
teachers will meet you over by the door.
Easy. Judah, don't knock somebody down
on your way out.
[Music]
All right. I see a couple faces who
might be new tonight. So, let me just
explain. We're going into the prayers of
the people now, which is a tradition
passed down through Christian history.
If you want to read along in the
screens, um the parts that we all say
together will be in red. And then in the
middle of the prayer, we'll leave some
space for you to speak out loud either a
name or a situation that you're carrying
into this space. But ultimately, we just
want to make room to name that we are
people that sometimes carry burdens and
that those are welcome here and that God
is with us and we are with each other in
the midst of our pain. So, um, if you
guys want to follow along with us,
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you
for the old and the sick, for the widow
and orphan, for the injured and
suffering. We pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed, the unemployed and
destitute, for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them.
We pray to you for the vulnerable, the
marginalized, and those unjustly
targeted for their race, gender,
sexuality, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
division
for the names in the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered me.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling. I will
walk in the land of the living, my soul
from death, my feet from stumbling. I
will walk in the land of the living.
[Music]
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living.
My soul from death, my feet from
stumbling. I will walk in the land of
the living.
[Music]
Sing. I will bless I will bless you Lord
for you heard my cry. I reach out my
hand and you saved my life. I will bless
you Lord for you heard my plea and the
God of heaven turned his ear to me. I
will bless you Lord for unending love
for your grace and mercy rained down
from above. I will bless you Lord till
the very end. I will call on you as long
as I may live.
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered me.
Yes, I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling. I will
walk in the land of the living. My soul
from death, my feet from stumbling. I
will in the land of the living
[Music]
that's taken right out of Psalm 116 and
it says, "I love you, Lord, for you
heard my cry.
He heard my cry for mercy because he
turned his ear to me. I will call on him
as long as I live.
Then I called on the name of the Lord.
Oh God, save me. The Lord is gracious
and righteous. Our God is full of
compassion. He protects the
simple-hearted.
When I was in great need, he saved me.
Be at rest once more, oh my soul, for
the Lord has been good to you.
[Music]
Come to the
all who are thirsty.
[Music]
Come and drink.
Come to the table.
Oh, you are hungry.
[Music]
Come and feast
those who are weary,
those who are needy.
Come receive.
Come to the river.
Taste and see.
[Music]
Let's sing that again.
Come to the water
all you are thirsty.
Come and drink.
Come to the table.
All who are hungry.
Come in peace.
Those who are weary,
those who are need,
come receive.
Come to the river.
Taste and see.
Oh,
oh, my soul
thirst for you
and you alone.
Oh,
oh, my soul
thirst for you.
You alone.
I will taste and see that you are good.
Good to me.
You're good to me.
[Music]
I will taste
and see that you are good.
I will taste and see that you are good.
You're good to me.
Oh.
Oh
my soul
thirsts for you
and you alone.
Oh
[Music]
my soul
thirsts for you and you alone.
Oh.
Oh, my soul
thirsts for you
and you alone.
Oh,
oh, my soul
thirsts for you
and you alone.
[Music]
And I will bless you, Lord. For you
heard my cry. I reached out my hand and
you saved my life. I will bless you,
Lord, for you heard my
God of heaven turned his ear to me.
I will bless you Lord for unending
love for your grace and your mercy
raining down from above.
I will bless you Lord till the very
end. I will call on you as long as I may
[Music]
God. Thank you for being a God that we
can call on. One who hears our cry and
turns his ear to our plea.
One who meets us right where we're at at
our lowest point
and picks us up and gathers all the
pieces of our life and our story and
weaves it into a tapestry that is good,
that is beautiful, that has a purpose
and a calling.
Jesus, would we hear your voice
as you speak to us? Would we trust that
you are listening when we speak to you,
God? Would we meet you in those moments?
Would we seek them out?
Would we wait for you?
[Music]
God, would we learn to trust our creator
who made us good,
who has a plan,
who is still in the work of redemption
and restoration and unification.
God, would we sew it into the fabric of
our life? Where there is division, would
we bring peace? God, where there is
anger,
would we bring a gentle word?
Where there is unrest, God,
would we remember that you are calling
our souls back to rest.
Would we follow that call?
It's in the name of Jesus that we pray
all these things.
Amen.
Thank you guys. Um, as you sit, would
you turn to the people on your right and
left and say, "The peace of Christ be
with you."
In peace.
Welcome to the table. So glad to be with
you all. My name is Brett and I'm the
pastor here and yeah, it's a joy joy to
to be with you in this space and uh as
always to welcome those join us online.
Love y'all lots and especially anyone
here tonight who is new if this is your
first time or um first few times or
maybe just your first time in a long
time. We're really really glad that
you're here and uh we know it can it can
be a lot you know emotionally depending
on church backgrounds and things. it can
just be a whole lot to come through
those double doors. So, um thank you for
for being with us uh tonight. So, this
is uh the third and the final part uh in
our series titled The Good Book, Fresh
Insights, uh into an ancient text. And
uh we've really been kind of just
wrestling with what scripture is, uh how
to read it, how to interpret it, um
really well. And uh like I mentioned
last week, for a lot of this series I've
been drawing from a book by John Bear,
the theologian John Bear named uh in
accordance with the scriptures and he
hails from the Eastern Orthodox kind of
tradition. Um but tonight's a little
different. I'm I'm drawing a bit more
from Father Richard Roar. There's
specifically a lecture he gave uh on
basically how um Jesus interpreted
scripture. And so uh so I'm drawing more
from that. In fact, I'll link to in my
e-letter this week kind of his whole
talk. talk. So, I've kind of grabbed a
few things from that and then kind of
done some my own stuff. And um so this
is with that in mind, the title of my
message tonight is how did Jesus
interpret scripture? I thought it was a
really intriguing um kind of way to
frame it. You know, we often kind of can
talk in the church about well how should
we interpret scripture and you know what
what's your take on this and whatever.
And it's interesting to actually ask the
question like well how did Christ do it?
You know since he was preaching and
teaching and talking with people and
explaining the Bible and you know
interacting with it. obviously he didn't
have like the New Testament or whatever
um but still had many Old Testament
scriptures and all that. So, uh that's
kind of how we're um or what we're going
to be delving into. And I think one
really kind of obvious point just to
make right off the bat is that uh Jesus
himself believed that the the father,
the one he called father, was speaking
to us in the scriptures. And I think
that's actually really important. I want
to name that right here at the beginning
because, you know, in all of our kind of
questioning and and even kind of
critiquing and I've done plenty of that
in the the last few weeks. Uh I I think
it can be easy to get into a kind of
skeptical place with the Bible, you
know, where we have we've seen some of
the harvest. We've seen how it how it
can get interpreted and kind of deployed
in the world in like dangerous and and
painful ways, like painful for people
literally in this room, you know. So,
that can kind of get us a little
sideways with the scriptures, you know,
we're just like, I don't know about
this. And I I just want to name like,
hey, but but Christ did believe like God
was speaking in and through these texts.
And uh I think that's that's important
to um remember. So, now having said
that, you know, still that question kind
of looms like okay, but but how did he
understand God to be speaking? you know,
like how did he interpret it? How did he
explain it? And uh and so that's what
we'll be kind of getting into. So, this
kind of leads in well to our big idea
for today, um which is this. If I had to
just summarize like the whole sermon in
one line, uh it would be this. Jesus
interpreted scripture with a prejudice
of love,
mercy, forgiveness, and inclusion. That
phrase prejudice of love is is from the
late Rachel Held Evans. Um, but I wanted
to kind of expand it, you know, because
I think there's that word love carries a
lot of weight. But what's that getting
at? Well, I think it's it's more than
just kind of loving feelings or
something. You know, it's really there's
some weighty theological um meaningful
things for our lives, you know? It's
it's not just like he interpreted with
good vibes. And that's not what even
Rachel Evans is getting at with that
prejudice of love. It's really about he
interpreted through this lens of mercy,
of forgiveness, of justice, of
compassion. You know, he held these
things at like the forefront as he uh
read and explained it. So, what I'm
going to do is give kind of walk through
three examples tonight of this. So, lots
of lots of Bible tonight and I'll do a
lot of summarizing as well. Um, so this
first example of Jesus doing this is
Leviticus 19 and the neighbor. So, this
is uh one of actually I think it might
be the only text from the book of
Leviticus that Jesus quotes. And it's
interesting as we get into it, you'll
see he's like incredibly
selective in his reading, like in his
interpreting. Selective. I'm thinking
like he has no problem sort of ignoring
all sorts of like stuff around it, even
the context of the passage. like he'll
just ignore so much of it and like zero
in on like one little part. So he's very
selective. He can also be quite
reductive in the sense of kind of like
boiling it down into this in a way where
you might kind of question like well
does it all really boil down into that,
you know, given the broader context. He
just he had no problem being like quite
selective, quite um reductive and uh
what I would call kind of I would search
for a word for this like kind of a uh
giving a kind of the spirit you you
always interpret according kind of the
spirit of the law as opposed to just the
pure like letter of the law was always
um kind of very open to to doing that.
So okay so what's this example? Well,
for one thing, chapter 19 of Leviticus,
it's like 37 verses long. And
it's really it's a kind of expansion of
like the Ten Commandments. So,
what what does he do here or what is
what is this passage about before we get
into how Jesus interprets it? Well,
verses one and two are about being holy
as God is holy. Verse three is about
honoring your father and mother and
observing the Sabbaths. You can hear
kind of if you're familiar with the Ten
Commandments, you can hear echoes of it
already there. Uh verse four is about
not making idols and false gods. Verses
5 through8 are about various sacrifices
and offerings and how when you burn the
sacrifice you should eat it like on that
day or the next day but not the third
day because if it's the third day well
then you get you are to be utterly cut
off from your people is the the kind of
language that's quite intense. Verses 9
and 10 are about leaving some food on
the edges of your field for the poor
which is quite beautiful. Verses 11
through 18 are all ethical principles
like don't lie or steal or defraud
people or slander them or withhold their
wages. Verse 19 also gets a little
strange, at least for modern ears,
because it's it's that infamous passage
about not mating two kinds of animals
and not planting two kinds of seed in
the same field and not wearing clothing
made from two types of material.
Anyone doing that tonight? So
unbiblical, you know, oh no, polyester.
I'm so sorry. Um, so like and then
that's kind of and so on and so forth
for the whole passage. I mean it's
really it's like covering a lot of a lot
of ground. And honestly, this is exactly
the kind of text that at least as a
preacher could get me tied up in knots.
Like in essence, if someone said, "Okay,
Brett, preach a sermon on Leviticus
chapter 19."
I would I would feel compelled to try to
make sense of the whole thing
because I don't want to come across I
don't want to be accused of being overly
selective. That the term for this um if
you're getting kind of like critiqued is
you're is the term cherry-picking.
You're cherrypicking scripture. meaning
you're just focusing on the, you know,
the feelgood parts, the love parts, but
you're not you're not really
incorporating all of the you're ignoring
the other, you know, I mean, like I
wouldn't want to be accused of that. So,
I would kind of do by my best to make
sense of the whole thing. Um, but Jesus
was different. In fact, he was asked to
actually do a harder thing than just,
hey, summarize Leviticus 19. really what
what the the religious leader asked him
to do was summarize the entire Old
Testament law. So not just Leviticus 19
and not just the book of Leviticus but
like half the Old Testament or
something. I mean like a huge question
of like hey just sum that up for me you
know like now again if I were asked to
do this this would be very difficult
like well you know I probably him and
haw a lot like yeah the the Bible's a
very big book you know there's a lot of
script there's many different
interpretations and it's very
complicated and you know like uh Jesus
does absolutely none of that like
instead
he just goes like right to the heart. He
just plucks out one verse from the
middle of the chapter. Leviticus 19
verse 18, love your neighbor as
yourself.
You'll notice it says um in the little
up here on the screen it says B. That's
because he doesn't even quote the entire
verse. It's literally like the middle
portion. If you ever see a little like
19A, that means oh it's like the first
sentence in the verse, but the verse is
like multiple sentences, you know? So
it's like literally he just chooses like
this little this little part of one
verse and is like that.
That's what it's about, right? No
context, no broader explanation. He just
cherrypicks the passage and says this is
what's most important. This is what the
the father cares about.
Right? You got the whole book of
Leviticus. And he's like, five words.
Love your neighbor as yourself.
That's it. Like, what? I mean, come on.
There's What about that stuff about
clothing and sacrifices and utterly cut
off from your people and you know what I
mean? Like, we could just go to town on
Jesus. You're not being faithful to the
scriptures. you know, which is sort of
ironic for us to look at Jesus and tell
him, right, how to read the Bible, how
to interpret it. Oh, you're
cherrypicking the Bible, Jesus. You
know, like, well, apparently he just had
no issue doing it. Why? Because he saw
like this is the heart. Everything else
is just commentary, right? This is an
example of Jesus prejudice of love when
it comes to scripture. He had no problem
being quite selective, quite reductive
in his interpretations, always looking
to the spirit of the text, not just the
letter. Second example, Isaiah chapter
61 in the day of the Lord to kind of
give this some context. Jesus has just
come back from his 40 days of testing in
the wilderness by the devil. And we so
we pick up the story. This is Luke
chapter 4-20.
Jesus returned to Galilee and the power
of the spirit and news about him spread
through the whole countryside. He was
teaching in their synagogues and
everyone praised him. By the way, this
is early in Jesus ministry. So, this is
when he was getting a lot of praise.
Later, things changed. But at least for
now, boy, he's he's people really liking
this guy. So, he went to Nazareth where
he had been brought up. And on the
Sabbath day, he went into the synagogue
as was his custom. He stood up to read
and the scroll of the prophet Isaiah was
handed to him. If you were here for
earlier in the series, you know, we
talked a lot about scrolls and versus
books and it's interesting how the Bible
put into a book. So, we start to think
of it in different ways, you know. So,
this is a good example here. Jesus,
right, didn't read from the Bible, but
he actually unrolled a scroll.
So, uh picks up this scroll the prophet
Isaiah was handed to him unrolling.
found a place where it is written, "The
spirit of the Lord is on me because he's
anointed me to proclaim good news to the
poor. He sent me to proclaim freedom for
the prisoners, recovery of sight for the
blind, to set the oppressed free, to
proclaim the year of the Lord's favor."
Then he rolled up the scroll,
gave it back to the attendant, and sat
down. The eyes of everyone in the
synagogue were fastened on him.
He began by saying to them, "Today this
scripture is fulfilled in your hearing."
Now, you might be able to feel like this
is a rather tense scene,
right? You can feel that people have
some sense of expectation, right? Since
the text says their their eyes are
fastened on him. Now, you might say,
"Well, of course, because he's standing
up and he's reading, you know, but
you'll notice actually in uh I think
it's verse 20 where he actually he reads
it, then he sits down and that's when it
says everyone's eyes are fastened on
him." This is kind of his mic drop
moment. So, actually he sits down,
everyone's looking at him and then he
says, "Today the scripture is fulfilled
in your hearing." Now, for our purposes
though, what's fascinating about this
passage is actually that Jesus left off
a very key line. Here's how the the full
text from Isaiah chapter 61:es 1-2 that
he's of course of course reading from as
he unreads the scroll or unrolls the
scroll. This is what he's reading from.
The spirit of the sovereign Lord's on me
because the Lord's anointed me to
proclaim good news to the poor. He has
sent me to bind up the brokenhearted, to
proclaim freedom for the captives and
reliefs from darkness for the prisoners,
to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor
in the day of the vengeance of our God.
So you can see what he left off there.
This is Jesus.
And again, I can already hear my
Christian siblings critiques, perhaps
not from this room, but maybe from
others, you know, of Jesus, look at you
playing fast and loose with the
scriptures, you know, cherrypicking the
texts, keeping all of the the compassion
and the the love and, you know, the the
justice, binding up the brokenhearted,
proclaiming freedom to those in
captivity, the year of the Lord's favor,
but then leaving off what to some in the
church at least,
is uh what we perceive as the most
important part. You know, the part where
we can vent all of our vengeance and
resentment and rage, you know, at those
outsiders, those failures, those evil
people, those who one day God will get.
And Jesus is like,
nope.
Just leaves it off. Now, I should
mention, uh, beginning a week from, so
two weeks from today, uh, we're going to
start a series on esquetology, the end
of this cosmos, this era, and all that.
Um, which is, I think, good timing since
Jesus was supposed to come back last
Wednesday, but then didn't. So, we'll
be, if you were in the Tik Tok world,
you were aware of like a big prediction.
It was like a whole thing. It was kind
of weird. So, anyway, so we'll get into
that and that at that time, we'll talk
some about like hell and judgment and
and all of that. Um, for now I'll I'll
just say this. I think the the kind of
key theological point I want you to grab
from this is that the father, mother,
God's heart towards all of her children
is never one of vengeance,
rage, and violence.
God's heart is always forever unending
love, mercy, forgiveness, and
compassion.
You say, "Wait, what? How can this be?
Have you not read the Bible? Have you
not read Isaiah 61?" I mean, it says
right there, black and white, it says,
"Vengeance."
Well, that's the thing. To be a
Christian is actually to read the Bible
a little bit differently. It is to read
it as Jesus read it. Can you see the
difference there? It's not just to read
the Bible. Just I'm just gonna open this
up and just do whatever it says. Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. It is to read
the scriptures as Jesus read them. To
interpret them the way he did, which is
with this this prejudice of love, right?
It's to read it in light of the life,
death, and resurrection of Christ. to uh
to kind of expand on this and I want to
quote pastor Brian's on that the reason
um we read in this way is because we
believe that God is like Jesus. God has
always been like Jesus. There's never
been a time when God was not like Jesus.
We haven't always known this. But now we
do.
What does he mean now we do? in light of
the revelation who is Christ. And now we
realize right you at first we we saw in
part now we see more clearly right as
Jesus said if you've seen me you've seen
the father
that leads us to example three this is
Leviticus chapters 11-15
and the notion of purity. So, a few
years ago, we did a uh a whole series on
Richard Beck's wonderful book uh
unclean. That's a that's a good if you
want to like a good if you're a reader
of books, that's a good one to to get.
And so, basically, Becky's a Christian
and he's a psychologist and he studied
something called discussed psychology,
which honestly sounds like sort of well
sounds kind of gross, but it's honestly
it's like fascinating. So the the kind
of
uh the core idea is basically like all
of us all you know we all find certain
things like disgusting and impure you
know just in in life. And the the trick
though is
the way our sense of disgust
naturally kind of hooks up with
morality.
In other words, we go from thinking of
certain or go from finding certain like
things, you know, kind of disgusting,
impure, unclean to what? Or really to
who? People.
We start to then translate that into
like we see people as disgusting,
impure, unclean.
And it's it's tricky though because
like on the one hand we kind of can't do
without this
uh like we might think like oh just do
away with that you know but you can't
really do away with discuss psychology
and also you can't just do away with
morality like in essence there there
really is a a we seem to have this kind
of inner sense of um like up and down
like if you talk to people even like
even if they're not Christians or even
religious they'll still have this sense
sense of like certain activities,
certain things elevate me, you know,
raise me up higher like higher towards
my my true self or higher towards God or
divinity or something, you know, and the
reverse we also people get this sense of
like
you know like that thing like that kind
of degraded me or that like brought me
um lower
and and so we do we have this sense of
kind of being driven down down towards a
more like beastlike
existence, you know, kind of um selfish,
rapacious um almost animallike. And so
what discussed psychology studies is um
is sort of that phenomena. And I think
it's fascinating if you take all that I
just named and then under start reading
scripture with that in mind,
uh it like it becomes absolutely
fascinating. So, and specifically read
Leviticus chapters 11-15 with this in
mind. So, what is 11-15 all about? For
the sake of time, again, I won't read it
all, but basically, it's just a summary
of like all the purity laws of the Old
Testament. So, you know, things uh clean
and unclean foods, purification rituals
after childirth, sex, ministration, pure
and impure bodies, like for instance,
those with like skin lesions and the
boundaries of how close they can get to
others. uh purification rituals for
homes with mold and standards of
cleanliness there. Right? So, you can
kind of see how this all becomes this
like swirl, this complicated swirl of
like some of it practical, healthful,
but also like moral, religious,
social, communal
purity.
And now I want you to call to mind
Jesus.
Think of the people
he interacted with.
The woman with a case of bleeding, the
lepers with their lesions and missing
fingers and toes, the Gentiles with
their unclean bodies and foods and
homes. And now think of Jesus
interaction with the Pharisees, the
religious leaders of the day, and his
critiques of them.
This leads us to the third and final
insight about Jesus and scripture. You
see, religious folks, we are very
tempted to basically get all about
uh kind of purity and morality. Like we
we are very tempted to obsess over our
own external moral purity, right?
policing the boundaries of the body and
excluding
those we deem unclean from our social
spheres. And this is something we feel
um very acutely here as Christians often
do this to to us.
And the trick is again
in keeping kind of with our theme, our
our siblings in Christ, they have their
Bible verses to back them up, right? Be
holy as I am holy. There are rules and
laws and standards and those who are not
measuring up
can contaminate us with their own moral
ritual uncleanness.
But here again, this is where Jesus just
cuts.
He just cuts at those readings and
interpretations.
He says in Matthew 23, beginning in
verse 25, "Woe to you teachers of the
law and Pharisees, you hypocrites. You
clean the outside of the cup in the
dish." Just a hint, he is not actually
talking about cups and dishes right now.
But inside
they're full of greed and
self-indulgence.
Blind Pharisee, blind religious person.
First clean the inside of the cup in the
dish, and then the outside will be clean
also.
Woe to you teachers of the law and
Pharisees, you hypocrites. You're like,
you're like whitewashed tombs. Oh, you
look beautiful. You're so beautiful on
the outside, but on the inside, you're
full of the bones of the dead and
everything unclean.
Right? This is the perfect example of
Jesus looking beyond the letter of the
law to the spirit to the heart of the
law. He's like, "Look, you're obsessed.
You're obsessed with with the the
washing of hands and cups and all manner
of outward observance,
looking good at church, you know,
whatever.
When what? When God is looking to the
heart,
God's looking to the heart. And in fact,
the very obsession with purity
is what drives you to condemn, to
distance
yourselves, he says, from the very
people I'm inviting you to love.
Boy, there's a lot of that going on in
our world right now.
But again, Jesus interprets all of
scripture
through this lens of love.
To close us out, I want to say this. In
many ways, I think Jesus sums up our
series so well. Actually, it's in in a
verse or two, a verse um just before the
one we just read. This is verse 23 of
Matthew 23. He says, "Woe to you
teachers of the law and Pharisees, you
hypocrites. You give a tenth of your
spices, mint, dill, cumin. But you've
neglected the more important matters of
the law,
justice,
mercy,
faithfulness.
You should have practiced the latter
without neglecting the former.
In other words, he's saying like, yes,
by all means, you know, continue to in
this case tithe, right? But you've got
to know the heart of scripture. What is
this all about? It is justice. It is
faith. It is mercy. It is forgiveness.
It is compassion.
Right? In short, may all of our study
and our reading and our meditating on
scripture, may all of our memorizing and
contemplating, may it actually lead us
to the goal,
the goal Christ intended that we would
be this kind of people,
a church of great love.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." Then he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take it. Drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me." And so for a few
thousand years now, Christians have
gathered at the table to connect again
with the risen Jesus
to long to be people who aren't just,
you know, good churchy folks on the
outside, but actually people of that
that transformative love that our world
so desperately needs. And this is a key
practice where we we come in in touch
with that. we come in touch with Christ
again and pray and yearn for that
filling of God's spirits that we could
go out from this place uh and ready to
to spread and share that beauty. So the
way we'll um go about this is we'll just
kind of go rowby row. We'll start here
at the front and we'll form one line
right here in the middle. When one row
is kind of done, then the next one can
jump up and get in line. Uh we practice
what's called an open table. So if
you're here tonight, uh you're welcome
to participate regardless of your like
exact, you know, denomination or
affiliation or doctrinal beliefs. You
know, if if something in you wants to
connect with the risen Christ, then
you're free to uh come forward and join
us in this time. Having said that,
there's also no pressure. If you're in a
place where you'd rather not
participate, that's that's perfectly
okay, too. Uh you should know the red is
wine, the white is grape juice, and then
finally, you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like. Some folks like
to come and kneel here at the front.
Some partake immediately. Some return to
their seats. But no one will lead you
through the exact moment of taking. You
can just do that on your own. So this is
the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord. And
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come,
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you who feel like you failed, come. Come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
We're going to close out with a song and
you guys are welcome to just sit and
listen and take it in. Um, I feel like
right now especially, it's really easy
to get lost in all the different
opinions of how we should and shouldn't
interpret the Bible, how we should and
shouldn't live out the Bible, what it
means. It can be very stressful, very
panicinducing.
Um, just scroll through my Instagram
feed and you see like very, very, vastly
different opinions of what it means to
live like Jesus. And um I find songs
like this to be really helpful because I
feel like a lot of us are trying our
best. And I believe that God meets us
there and says it's not so much about
the trying. It's about the being the
child of God loved, seen, known. That's
when we have something to offer. When we
live from that space,
[Music]
dear God,
I've been trying awful hard to make you
proud of me.
But it seems
the harder that I try or the hard it
becomes.
And I feel like giving up
most
of the time.
[Music]
Dear God,
I've been chasing their approval and
it's killing me.
[Music]
And then I know
the more I try to prove the less I had
to show.
And I'm stuck inside my head.
most
of the time.
But if I pray a little harder, if I
follow all the rules, I wonder, could I
ever be enough?
Cuz I try and I try just to fall back
down again.
And I ask myself, why do I try to chase
the wind? I should lean into the
mystery. Maybe hope is found in the
melody.
I want to try again.
Oh, I'm going to try again.
Dear child,
I hope you know how much I love you and
I'm proud of you.
[Music]
Please believe
the thoughts I have for you will never
change or fade away.
[Music]
When you felt like giving up,
I
never did.
[Music]
Cuz I'm not scared of imperfections
or the questions in your head.
Just know that you have always been
enough.
And you tried and you tried and I saw
you wrestle with every how and every
why. I was right there listening.
So just fall into the mystery and I'll
meet you here in the melody. Oh, try
just to try again.
>> Oh child, won't you try again?
My child, you can love again.
[Music]
Thank you so much for joining us
tonight. We're so glad you're here. Um,
if you're a visitor and this is your
first time, please uh there's some
visitor cards on the small table on the
way out your door or you can uh fill out
a visitor card online with the QR code
at the tabletx.org.
Um,
if you um are feeling generous and want
to contribute to what we're doing here,
uh you can also do that via the QR code
or the tabletx.org.
Um so those opportunities exist and are
available all the time.
um would like to remind you we have a
series of meetups as well. So um and the
need for community and small groups and
especially just as we go through things
the need for closeness with each other.
Um those are also available throughout
the week at different times in different
locations and you can find all that
information at the QR code. So um if you
take nothing else away the QR code has
all the information. Um let me send you
into the week of the benediction. So um
if you just put yourself under a posture
of receiving,
[Music]
you are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day.
So as you go ahead in your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, you are worthy, and you are
accepted just as you are. And go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend those same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with. Be blessed and we'll
see you next Sunday. Cuz
[Music]
I'm not scared of imperfections
or the questions in your head. Just know
that you have always been enough.
Cuz you tried and you tried and I saw
you wrestling with every
wine. I was right there listening
and fall into the mystery. I meet you
here in the mey.
Try just to try again.
My child, you can't try again.
[Music]
>> My child, you can love again.